hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay now we got this
dwarven mechanism here Lydia's got her
super attractive
super attractive helmet and shield combo
going on there but you know whatever
hides her face although it's mean the
charge level of a staff is based off Wow
I've never seen anything like this
before is what Lydia would say woo hey
now offered ow
what the hell that hurt I like really
hurt okay someone told me that Lydia
can't die it's just if I by accidentally
hit her she'll die bad doesn't want that
oh yeah - and it's kill screen on you
stupid spear I make sure I don't kill
Lydia ah there you go
feel better now and someone said that I
could take like the vents crap and stuff
it just whoops
and just ivan toys screw you power
thank you stop it level up my enchanting
my black circles through that and those
minor potions is lydia you okay over
there I'm fine womp see Lydia this is
what you have to do to take care of
these enemies you just kind of deal with
them you can't play around with them you
can't flirt with them it just got a kill
kill them dead okay no sin Darian's
field laboratory my answer issue sand
Aryans field laboratory whose sin Darien
is with this place yeah the been scrap
metal so people who say
yeah I'll pick up a few pieces I mean I
there's a sack over here to mince fear
tonight wasn't that the thing the guy
gave me oh yeah okay Wow look at all
this holy crap is my stuff here
Wow Wow I think all these regions
Regents reagents keep you at give me
that I see it right there
thank you dear rerum dear Ennis I don't
know taking it crimson Nirnroot and what
are these colorful things at you well
how was that yep-yep-yep something
sparked a Dwemer cat
it's just a dwarf Cup nothing special
about it what's that no I don't care
don't care all right got everything
I think Skellington Oh soon darien okay
get his journal he's it's like a
question why there's even more stuff
okay
that was useful and stuff crap I can
stop creeping now and do the creep ah
any of you listen to the Lonely Island
man what is with these is weird
mushrooms just floating up everywhere
this is definitely weird I've never seen
anything like this maybe I just haven't
gone into Evan going to ruins before
this is really cool and this is oh
that's a big guy whoa charas is charas
what the hell ah you [ __ ]
oh you douche nozzle whoa I won't [ __ ] I
can't get to him the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do I guess I'll use my my frigate
frack is it hmm dwarf in BO favorite
that whip it get ready to top nope can't
back up
I'll headshot someone's shooting magic
at me oh yeah app headshots I'll lose
this um Oh bro oh good thing my archery
skills like 10 billion whoa that whoa
where'd Lydia Lydia cover cover me
please
Lydia Lydia I could really use your help
right here Lydia I'm dying would you
please
sword get ready to die
Palmer Hermitage Horace
briquette Fraga charas is dead
give that give me that give me that
babies will be mine I'll eat them eat
them with my mouth whole damn this guy I
mean just screw him - screw him he's a
dick
oh [ __ ] you can use it huh don't have
any gah Frick he'll he'll hell yeah
badass now miss me dick
get ready to die because this is stupid
oh yeah headshot i'll miss me dick oh
yes so awesome oh man that was another
hit ohh
10 points to Gryffindor did I just kill
it - guy shot her in the [ __ ] face I
just shot her in the frickin face oh oh
you didn't see it I don't know if you
can see it was so small but I could ah I
saw an outline of a dwarven helm and it
was just like bu arrow right into her
face ah kill Lydia oh no my save it's so
long ago
[ __ ] don't I have a load yes please
ah damn it why would she do that why
would she be so stupid I don't even know
even know if there's a way for she to
get up there I'm going that way through
this screw this screw this charging it
out of my way and prepared I can't
believe that [ __ ] that is [ __ ] it
just so happens that Lydia popped up at
around the corner at that exact moment
and in the exact right place for me to
headshot her and kill her
who is she low on help anyway oh god I I
don't even know I don't even know that
was worse
yeah you better die that was like the
worst luck possible of anything I've
ever gone through that was quite
possibly the most [ __ ] thing I've
ever seen in my life
I mean honestly come on
you die you mother all right yo [ __ ]
you're dead you're not dead you're dead
good stay dead
that's heavy though
yes that's way too heavy be important to
carry someone said like keep it at a 1
to 1 to 10 ratio of weight to value
alright a little buggy I don't know
where Lydia won again but I'm not we our
archery is bad ok
oh [ __ ] hell ok his son of a [ __ ]
deal please go faster some poison
alright buddy
get ready to die there like a better
healing spell [ __ ] you [ __ ] you two
get out of here give your [ __ ] oh there
you are
really Lydia oh I swear Lydia
what am I gonna do with you Lydia I
swear
I'm going to that big mushroom looking
things
oh no not again not again
not dealing with your [ __ ] don't I have
like a sprint attack that does double
critical damage like yeah yeah buddy you
stay out of the way
well done well I take care of business
I've cut an arrow in my head don't know
how it got there but it was there is
this right spot no it's farther back
there okay all right all right this is a
long way to go for a friggin Elder
Scroll I guess it couldn't be easy to
find fits this geode Ella's geode
Grippit Quang Wang Wang Chuang Fang
hello corundum yes right yeah got my
pickaxe what if you go through the whole
game with the pickaxe rose for a
woodcutter's axe okay I think in
something need those water there you're
a big careful Lydia that oh this is a
reflection is it maybe yes uh whatever
Lydia we're going where are we going
phoo geode
pick ax flip gibbet funny - Burt DB
heady soul gem yeah we got any think I
got a single or what who's fighting over
there oh hello tough these little guys
are really tough actually
oh no they're not how's Ally oh you
can't run yeah and what he's alive what
Lydia go take care of that I got places
to be
can't be bothered with such trivialities
such as that and this place is freakin
huge
I mean if I if I was just you know
playing fit playing for play I would
like to be exploring but for now Oh am I
going there okay this place is freaking
huge
I guess if whoa I gotta check that out
what the hell is going on there that
looks way too cool to pass up
I subscribe don't know why damn contacts
what for you follower service Oh Linea
you just had to get in the way
Lydia stop getting in the way
here's what's going on up here
Sheila are like these guys are like
enslaved techo pass huh
looks like a whole mess of stuff but I'm
gonna ignore it okay I'll come back here
later if I need to
man how many dungeons are this in-depth
and detailed in this game I don't even
know because this is crazy I know this
is like meant for hurts most likely
meant just for them that's weird for the
Elder Scroll that's here but
other knife they're like other Dwemer
ruins that are just as big it would be
crazy adventuring how much about how
much game is in this game I don't even
know what the hell is this tower of dark
it's by ancient ancestor ms arc we
dropped the Z that's how you really
spell my name is just a Z is silent
Lydia where'd you go Jia Jia Yu ji ha
where did you go where did you where did
you go Lydia we have got things to do
not much time to do them in up in the
door must be close oh this looks fine
see
what have we got here
hmm it's a big Alba and what's in the Oh
a scroll sitting chair two chairs bugs
cops or people to sit around here
staring at the dumb thing here hmm
activate activate activate
whoa
oh look ah ah okay it's like a puzzle
then this means the other one goes in
here the other thing they gave me right
we're kid I have no idea what I'm doing
whoa something happened it opened I'm
guessing that's right that's correct
this but no no nope hello shoot do woo
ah the hardest puzzle in the world but
hello
Oh doggy looks like a pile of this is
some great whoa up that's it that's it
let it out you're missing a monumental
moment in history I'm gonna travel back
in time or something
hey demon unlocked elder knowledge read
the Elder Scroll at the time you know
the time wound where all that time is
bleeding out you know it's got those
time scabs a big little time scar
running up running up its arm you know
the time wound I don't know where Lydia
when she died I swear so pissed at her
oh this would have been so easy if I
just bash down this friggin gate Lydia
where are you Lydia please tell me you
did not die is Lydia dead did Lydia die
oh let me just fast travel somewhere
she's not there then she's probably dead
oh okay let's go to the time wound which
is up on the time Mountain at the top of
the throat of the time world where I go
back in time to save the time future
Lydia
oh she's dead isn't she
Oh oh no oh no I think she might be
actually dead forever cuz I didn't oh oh
no oh no no no no oh no oh yeah poor
Lydia were they I think she's actually
dead
I think she's gone guys I think she's
gone forever
how have it Raquelle all right
the Elder Scroll yeah heat grill by
looking at your eyes are your no time
shudders and its touch uh-huh yes no
question you are doomed driven Colgan
akatosh the very bones of the earth are
at your disposal okay go then fulfill
your destiny take the scroll to the time
wound do not delay Alduin will be coming
he cannot miss the signs uh-huh so well
sacrifices must be made for the greater
good Lydia will be remembered I don't
know how she died I had nothing to do
with it I was running away from that
fight because I thought that you know
whoa oh there's a because I thought that
she would follow eventually I didn't
think that she could die how did she die
oh I need to read the thing look eldest
there is whoa
Oh
ah learner's from the Nord heroes
they'll be like one night are going in
battle dal-su thoraseal
today alguns lordship will be restored
again but I honor your courage creep
wolf ah cream die now in vain
Dragonborn here
not bad I'm flinching at that fire can I
do something okay move hello yeah
Billie Jean oh alright then my damn good
job
be gone how glorious day is it not have
you no thought beyond the blooding of
your blade mm-hmm
what else is there battle below go zeal
foul doing does not rise to our
challenge I fear all may be lost uh-huh
you worry too much brother victory will
hello where'd you come from
why does Alduin hang back we've staked
everything on this plan of yours old man
old man he will come he cannot ignore
our defiance and why should he fear us
even now he run at him well for
- my blade gets older himself both sorry
feel good [ __ ] they did not have dragon
rent once we bring him down I promise I
will cabbies Alduin cannot be slain like
a lesser dragon strengthen which is why
I brought the oldest woosh woosh
well yeah we agreed not to use it
I never agree and if you are right I
will not need it he will deal without
them ourselves we shall see soon enough
all the one approaches where I'd like to
see him really just the three of you me
Tom
him and Pauline ha ha ha 7 guard envied
us this day okay
all right then
cool
he's dead
yay Paarthurnax
to make mud
in
if I die today it will
okay
what that
hold on the wing sister hawk graduation
sacred realm to make this contractor ha
begone world either my words with older
bones in your own trick your perch on
this age and send him out you are
banished
the last
I could've eaten bar banished the bloody
did it
uh-huh yes the world eater is gone may
the spirits have mercy on our soul
uh-huh you just send them to our time
you weren't tough enough
oh now my objective is to feed out whoo
I get to find it right here now little
idiot my side this is for linear you
vaster Dovahkiin get already and dweet
your feet in southern girl ain't gonna
know sovngarde I'm a friggin Argonian
I'm going where our going okay I got it
bro barely I gotta use hey hold on I
gotta get this shout dragon you're out
here we go
mortal finite temporary really those are
the words for there some hateful words
my friend Jean use dragon rend if you I
do yeah did I get him waxed
hahahaha Oh
hey pops an axle
yeah
Oh God actually I should use like a lot
of these I've got tons here health
healing or if I stamina hell just frost
generation Bleu boob booth Berserker I
like that
let's do poison all right let's go let's
go [ __ ]
Oh Oh what the what the hell no no no no
no get down here a dragon rend you
thanks Bart the next you living isn't
gonna be the end of the kV Wow
oh yeah I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know what I'm doing but I'm doing
it well wait fit back here no you don't
whoops I missed out what do you wear to
go I don't want to get par than that
all right kill one of my friends
apparently
but
ten other one I don't know
well there he is okay there we go
got ya what the hell where I got it
this is stupid
yeah yep
I get him yeah [ __ ] I'm so suck come
here huh what everyone calls me I never
called my so Matt yeah I can't let my
health get too low or else he'll just
dance to kill me please oh I might
actually run out of health potions I
didn't realize I was gonna be like going
straight for him right after this do I
have anything else like you know nope
up all my brute strength actually what I
could do is I could be smart and use my
stamina potions ha nope not going
anywhere
[ __ ] what does what what are you doing
Paarthurnax
why the night don't be like that
pretty go
now that's a popular
I'm gonna win in the game
actually I might have to cut it I'm
after doing total cliffhanger and this
slide attracted ever
mostly because I have a Wimpy ass weapon
like low ten when I'm fighting hard got
ya right back
I'm already striking
and maybe I'll just do a really long
absolutely
come on Oh
Oh combat level
stay down uh-huh
greater than this up their level up
morrow
there it is there are still not high
enough
what I'm like who's like ridiculous I
must have like sprinted through the game
well I guess I can't do anything
whatever you're gonna die hmm what nope
super combat yeah
yep I sure have
what I am I'll do first born of akatosh
uh-huh my log is so good
Malaga's a lot to you too yeah are you
or anyone else
oh maybe this isn't the end of the game
maybe I was just dying out my ass you
cannot prevail against me I will have
lost you [ __ ]
okay all right what that was it
I can't dragon run you down oops I
missed anyway that's what all right then
I I kiss all right I was nowhere near
the end part the next part part the next
okay then I guess that didn't go over as
well as I planned but whatever talk to
me talk to me buddy document buddy loft
congra you truly have the voice of a
dov'è uh-huh I'll doings allies will
think twice after this victory right
Neely Rahim Moro ha ha true this is not
the final conga ha ha victory but Alduin
always was pop this should shake the
loyalty of the dough yes one of his
allies could perhaps the half Casa Hume
the palace in Whiterun a fine place to
trap one of alcohol yes but your soom is
strong yeah I used to visit him from
time to time I'd the hop Casa Yoon has
been known as dragon's reach ever since
all right then
ok I totally panicked on the whole it's
the end of the game thing I guess I was
hitting that [ __ ] way too early but
anyway I'm out of time for now so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always see you in the next part bye-bye